at this altitude I can run for my books
I've loved on the Tim Ferriss show is
exclusively brought to you by audible
there couldn't be a better sponsor for
this series my dear listeners and
readers I have used audible for so many
years as long as I can remember I love
it
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet I listen when
I'm taking walks I listen while I'm
cooking I listen whenever I can and if
you're looking for a place to start
I can recommend three of my favorites
the first is the Tao of Seneca by Seneca
if you want to hear my favorite letters
of all time touches on stoic philosophy
calmness under duress etc the next is
the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman GA IMA
n one of my favorites even if you're a
nonfiction purist this is the fiction
book that you need to listen to neo also
has perhaps the most calming voice of
all time in 3rd Gregg McEwan's
essentialism subtitle the disciplined
pursuit of less this is one of my
favorite books of the past few years
combines very well with the 80/20
principle but more inaudible every month
audible members get one credit for any
audiobook on the site plus a choice of
multiple audible originals from a
rotating selection they also get access
to daily news digests from the likes of
the New York Times Wall Street Journal
and The Washington Post as well as
guided meditation programs and here are
some other amazing audible features and
I use a bunch of these you can download
titles and listen offline anytime
anywhere I use this feature even when I
could get access I'll put my phone on
say airplane mode because I want to get
bothered with notifications and I'm
taking a walk to clear my head and you
can listen to you titles offline in a
case like that or on a plane or whatever
obviously I'm not flying much these days
the app is free and can be installed on
all smartphones and
tablets you can listen across devices
without losing your spot and whisper
sync is another feature I use quite a
lot I love reading my kindle in bed for
instance then picking up at the same
exact spot where I left off when I go
walking and listening the next day
Kindle and audio versions can be synched
up automatically it's just amazing and
if you can't decide what the listen to
don't sweat it you don't have to rush
you can keep your credits for up to a
year and use them for instance to binge
on a whole series if you like audible
offers just about everything podcasts
guided wellness programs theatrical
performances a list comedy and audible
originals you won't find anywhere else
and right now audible is offering you
guys that's Tim Ferriss show listeners a
free audiobook with a 30-day trial
membership and again my list if you want
to check them out the Tao of Seneca the
graveyard book essentialism those are
just three there's so many good ones out
there just go to audible.com slash tim
and browse the unmatched selection of
audio programs then download your free
title and start listening it's that easy
let's check it out go to audible.com
slash tim or text tim t IM - 500 500 to
get started today check it out
audible.com slash tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is usually my job to sit down with
world-class performers of all different
types startup founders investors chess
champions Olympic athletes you name it
to tease out the habits that you can
apply in your own lives this episode
however is an experiment and part of a
short-form series that I'm doing simply
called books I've loved I've invited
some amazing past guests close friends
and new faces to share their favorite
books describe their favorite books the
books that have influenced them changed
them transform them for the better and I
hope you pick up one or two new mentors
in the form of books from this new
series and apply the lessons in your own
life I had a lot of fun putting this
together inviting these people to
participate and have learned so so much
myself I hope that is also the case for
you please enjoy howdy Hattie my name is
Matt Mullenweg I am that co-founder of
WordPress which is open-source software
used by about actually about 35% of all
websites now
and I also run a company called
automatic' which is a fully distributed
company of over 1200 people that makes
services for WordPress and fun so things
like wordpress.com jetpack tumblr and
WooCommerce so this topic on favorite
books is very exciting to me because I'd
love to read somewhere go through a
bunch room as fast as I can and
basically four categories fun life
professional and then well actually two
final bonus categories like
mind-expanding authors where I just read
everything they publish so start with
the fun ones the first two are actually
collection of short stories which I love
because you can kind of work them in
between other readings almost like a
like a refresher while you're reading
longer things the first is called paper
menagerie
and other stories which is by Ken Lou
this is kind of sci-fi
honestly I have recommended this to a
ton of people and couldn't get a copy
for Tim before and they've loved it it's
just a huge variety of stories that
really make your mind think differently
and can lose honestly one of the authors
um new authors at least new to me
authors I'm most excited about he also
translated one of the three body problem
books and he just has a ton of great
work out second one is called some which
is for details from the after lives
since by a guy who's normally more of a
science writer and David Eagleman each
one of these stories is only two to
three pages long and it starts out at
the point of an afterlife beginning and
that sounds it doesn't do it justice
actually what I would do is maybe just
pick this up and check out the very
first story and see what it does to your
mind I love actually reading one of
these before I go to bed and I find that
it kind of resets my brain a little bit
and also sometimes gives me really cool
dreams I've also even read them to
people as gifts at Burning Man that's
how cool the stories are these first two
were actually a recommendations that I
got from a friend who's a designer named
Connie yang the third and the fun
section or fiction sections I recommend
is actually kind of a secret weapon in
that I've met a ton of other CEOs and
founders and folks who ultimately they
were highly highly influenced by this
book and that is the foundation by Isaac
Asimov it's actually a short series and
yeah it's it's just so wild how I'll
meet people from all walks of life
including CEOs of companies worth tens
of billions of dollars let's say this is
one of their most influential books
especially when they were young I read
this as a kid I think it's a great gift
for kids I actually recently have picked
it back up and I'm rereading it it holds
up very well but if you have any kind of
like young adults in your life that you
feel I could enjoy I like some really
interesting sci-fi just the concepts and
it kind of makes you think about the
world differently all right the second
category
I'm gonna call life things
so the first and foremost I'll put here
which is actually someone I recommended
that Tim had on the podcast and Krista
Tippett I was a great podcast called on
B and has a book called becoming wise
that covers a lot of her like a best of
all most of her work and I would say if
you're only gonna be run in the life
section that is the one I would
recommend the second that I'm going to
recommend is called
on grief and grieving which is by
Elisabeth kubler-ross kubler-ross
created that scale that you might have
heard of you know the five stages where
it's like anger denial acceptance blah
blah blah she actually created that and
this book was the last of I think three
books she did in her series and I was
actually finished posthumously by her
writing partner because as she was
writing this book she herself was
passing away this book was extremely
helpful and important to me and after my
father passed and I've recommended for a
number of folks including those who
don't have anyone in their life that's
currently ill or has recently passed it
is one thing that is certain for all of
us that you know we're gonna people in
our life or in a pass at some point and
how this book talks about pretty
grieving about breathing it really
opened up my mind to really be able to
process and deal with what was a total
whirlwind it still is in some ways a
whirlwind of emotions so this is what I
can recommend without hesitation to any
human eye on that topic a little bit and
this one is is probably gonna make you
cry if you read it is called one breath
becomes air by Paul Kenneth E and this
is also a little bit of a posthumous
book that was a story of a professor who
tragically found out he was not going to
make it and so what he did with his his
last bit of life and how he acted and
his family and everything beautifully
beautifully beautifully written very
very special book and finally on the
life side this one has a funny title but
it's a really really good book it's
called why Buddhism is true
by Robert White I Catholic you know this
wasn't a book I'm not Buddhist not
becoming Buddhists are no plans there
but I found that this book which takes
have a neuroscience view of you know
text and Buddhism Hinduism that go back
sometimes thousands of years it's really
really fascinating and it is an
interesting juxtaposition of kind of how
older wisdom intersects and interacts
really well with the latest findings of
science and how you can apply that to
your life to quiet your monkey mind to
be able to focus of course there's talk
about meditation and other things that
you probably heard a lot on tim's
podcast so this regardless of your
religious leanings or non-religious
leanings I would say as excellent and
great read all right this next category
section is the one where I have the most
books so hopefully you've made it
through the fun and life ones now you're
ready to be more professionally
successful each one of these has had an
influence and I would consider pivotal
to my success and the things I've done
in creating WordPress and automatic
first is relatively new and I wish it
had come out a decade before because I
could have saved a lot of trouble it's
called principles by Ray Dalio
who's one of the most successful hedge
fund investors and he runs his company
an extremely interesting way and this is
the first of I think several books he's
planning on doing where he spells out
the things he's learned he is what these
folks who has a dream Lee an analytical
mind writes down everything and checks
it later so if your mind is not as
analytical like mine is not quite there
actually I think probably few people in
the world are quite as analytical Ray
Dalio is I it can be I was a provocative
and challenged you to think in different
ways also pairs very well with the last
recommendation I'm going to do here for
great mental models the second is
another one with a not a great title but
really good book called nonviolent
communication which is by Marshall
Rosenberg
and this means nonviolent in the sense
that Gandhi was nonviolent or Martin
Luther King where it's not like don't
yellow people but more how is what we
say and how we say it sometimes doing
the opposite of what we intend so this
way to communicate the exact Siam's
thing in a better way that people will
be more receptive to whatever you're
saying this book I think I read
originally in like a personal context I
put in this section because I found that
it completely levels up all of my
communication where that was in family
relationships personal relationships and
we're probably had the biggest impact
was in my work relationships you know at
automatic we do a ton of communication
over text as well using our internal
tool p2 also a lot of slack and you know
sort of applying what I learned and by
reading nonviolent communication I found
I became more effective particularly at
text-based communication in kind of
getting the intention of my message
across speaking of being a distributed
company with lots of text communication
I want to recommend a book called remote
which by the folks over a base camp
Jason freed and David himer Hanson this
is probably the best guide available
right now to doing working remotely or
in a distributed fashion also Basecamp
formerly known as 37signals
it has a very refreshing no nonces first
principles way of working and I feel
like any company that can apply some of
the principles you can pick and choose
it's like a buffet book can probably
become a lot more effective and I guess
it's probably the best resource for
distributive work right now but I will
also take this opportunity to plug my
podcast which you can find a distributed
blog which is interviewing folks
including the Basecamp folks at some
point on how to be effective all scaling
distributed companies lighting is so key
and you might be detecting a theme here
and the book that's been most
influential my entire life there it was
called on writing or is called on
writing well by Williams ensler
writing to me is not just something for
communication it's also something that
really helps me learn how to think
better and I would point pretty much
anything significant that I've done in
my life it says something that I sat
down and wrote and really worked through
it in a written form first and I have
all sorts a hack sometimes I have write
things out longhand sometimes I type it
in simple notes sometimes I type in
WordPress sometimes I do it Google Doc
and collaborate with people sometimes I
just text my friends but this book I
would say is probably the classic for
improving the clarity of your writing
which therefore improves the clarity
were thinking of anything I've read and
I've probably read dozens of writing
books at this point because it is a
topic and genre a book which I find very
fascinating so save lots of time you
don't have to read the dozens of books
that I read just check out this one and
it will definitely level up your written
communication but a little esoteric for
this next one and talked about a book
which is a little more academic which is
by an author named George Lakoff and
it's called metaphors we live by there's
definitely a writing theme here so many
people don't know this but a lot of how
we talk is actually in metaphors what
this book breaks down is what these
metaphors are many of which you probably
use day-to-day without even realizing it
and how you can change how you use
metaphors to basically say what you're
trying to say and not negate what you're
trying to say
so as one example of metaphors that you
probably use all the time but don't
think about it as categories one that he
talks about the book as argument is war
as examples your claims are indefensible
he attacked every weak point in my
argument his criticisms were right on
target
I demolished his argument I've never won
an argument with him you disagree okay
shoot if you used that strategy he'll
wipe you out he shot down all of my
arguments if you listened there and
really dig in they'll see that there's
a lot of war metaphors and terminology
and imagery being used we're talking
about something not to do with Wartell
which is arguments there's all sorts of
examples like this including what I
found really fascinating which is
spatial metaphors and if you learn this
this actually I think goes to a bit too
how the mind works
which brings us pretty well to the final
one in this section which I recommend
also a fairly new book by Shane Paris
best known for Farnam Street which is
has a great podcast and it's great site
FS blog I believe and they're doing a
five volume series called the great
mental models you've probably heard
about mental models if you follow Warren
Buffett are Charlie Munger at all and in
fact previously there's this great book
called poor Charlie's Almanac which was
a collection of Charlie Munger speeches
where he really laid out a lot of his so
for very heterodox thinking things I've
made him very successful as half of the
pair has been probably one of the most
successful investors in history
alongside Warren Buffett these features
were not terribly accessible though they
had a lot of extraneous material they
were repetitive in some ways and the
book itself was a little hard to access
so these great mental models is a one if
you can't buy the hardcover like it's
it's one of the most beautiful books
I've actually interacted with in a long
time and if you're able to build what
they call this latticework of mental
models it can make you essentially
approach all sorts of situations much
faster or more effectively than you
would you're trying to figure out things
from scratch
every single time this pair is really
really well with principles by Ray Dalio
okay fourth category I'm gonna call
mind-expanding these are two books
actually ones I've just read this year
both of which go pretty well with
metaphors we live by
but around consciousness theory of mind
kind of how everything works one's a
little bit of an older book I think from
1980 and it's only available in print
which like everything else I've
recommended that you can get on the
Kindle or something what's called the
world is sound
nada Brahma it's by a German author
Joaquim Ernst parent and basically goes
through just really really interesting
it as a musician myself I had learned
about things like the harmonic series as
an overtone series which is a beautiful
set of whole number of ratios that sort
of govern western music and the twelve
tone scale and things but I did know as
much about just versus even intonation
and how also these ratios show up kind
of everywhere in life be it you know
from how plants form to the orbit of the
planets to lots of things I have Google
a lot as I read this book some of it is
still spot-on so if it's been we have
sort of newer understandings of some
things it talks about but again this is
the mind expanding category so I always
say it is it interesting
I'll put it as provocative as well read
I'm not something that you agree with
everything in the book but something
that probably opens your mind to a lot
of things you hadn't thought about
before or never even considered I would
also say it's completely accessible to
non musicians as well as musicians I
just found it particularly interesting
because it applied some things I had
learned in different different sort of
fields or different context in a more
scientific context the second which is
also a fairly fairly new book is called
conscious a brief guide to the
fundamental mystery of the mind this is
by Annika Harris and this is you know
what they call the hard problem what is
consciousness
where is it coming from who is who's
listening to me talk right now and who
is it that listens to you talk to
yourself all of these questions I find
endlessly fascinating and as an area of
in some ways a lot of study and in some
ways much less than you would expect so
this was a very short book you can
actually get through it just an hour to
so I feel actually even better
recommending it because it packed a huge
amount of information in value into a
very kind of tidy package I always love
when books are just as long as they need
to be in no longer
so this will definitely give you lots to
talk about at parties or with friends
and I find just it's good from a
philosophical point of view to sometimes
think about and ponder these bigger
questions okay
last I promised you the authors that I
read literally everything they publish
no matter what it is and these are
besides Tim of course because if you're
listening you probably already read all
his books to folks I'm gonna recommend
here and I apologize have expense with
their names but the first is you've all
know her her Ari he's probably best
known for sapiens which is I say you've
all is an author who can synthesize a
ton of information across history both
modern and older and represent it in
like a really compelling way so I I love
sapiens like everyone didn't read
holiday Oz but I would say my favorite
if you're gonna pick one book of his
versus his last one which was 21 lessons
for the 21st century super fascinating
very cool to see a historian look at the
contemporary things and I thought he was
spot-on
if any of us thoughts the second is a
much more controversial author but I
would say ever since I was exposed to
one of his early works fooled by
randomness and black swan I will
probably always be a fan of Nassim Taleb
and he is you know a writer who is not
humble who you know is not afraid of
sprinkling tons of obscure references
and not obscure references you could
easily take one of his books and then
read 20 or 30 others but he is a
provocative thinker he is an original
thinker in many ways he's a fun writer
you know he writes in a very engaging
style and whether you agree with her or
disagree with him I think your mind will
be sharper for having read his work and
considered it Black Swan was I think the
very first when I read of his had a
wonderful introduction but all of his
books are quite fun and funny and I will
continue to keep
reading everything that he publishes
alright again my name is Matt Mullenweg
co-founder of WordPress CEO of automatic
if you'd like to check out more of my
random musings my blog is at ma TT I'm
on Instagram Twitter and Tumblr at photo
Matt hph OTO ma TT and I love hearing
from folks so you can also check out
some of my photos at matte top blog
I've been publishing online for a long
time so I'm sorry I have so many places
but I I learned a lot from Tim's podcast
and I can't wait to hear what other
people's book recommendations are
because I'm always looking for new
things to read so if you end up reading
e of these drop me a note or a tweet or
something if you like them if you hate
them and I hope you have a wonderful day
bye bye hey guys this is Tim again just
a few more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet Friday do
you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday an event provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favourite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do it could include a
favorite articles that I have read and
that I've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour work week come that's
four hour work week calm all spelled out
and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy
[Applause]